انيسه اكثر تعاطفا من الرجال ربما هو
بديهي بالنسبه لنا بحكم الخبره الحياتيه
لكن تم تاكيد ها الان على اساس علمي دراسه
جديده اجراها علماء من جامعه كامبردج
حللوا فيها بيانات اكثر من 300,000
مشاركنا الرجال والنساء في 57 دوله
الدراسات تهديفه للبحث فيما يعرف بالتعاطف
المعرفي وهو القدره على تخيل ما يفكر فيه
او يشعر به شخص اخر ووضع نفسك مكانا
الاخرين لفهم ما يمرون به
سجلت النساء درجات اكثر من الرجال في
اختبار العيون الذي يقيس التعاطف المعرفه
حيث يطلب من المشاركين النظر الى صوره شخص
ثم اختيار كلمه تصف ما يفكر فيه هذا الشخص
او يشعر به بمجرد النظر الى المنطقه
المحيطه بعيونهم باختصار تفوقت النساء من
جميع الاعمار في درجه التعاطف وفي المعرفه
في 36 دوله وتعادلنا مع الرجال في الدول
المتبقيه
[موسيقى]
ليس تحيزا للنساء لكن لانهن الاكثر تعاطفا
مع الاخرين مقارنه بالرجال فالنساء يمتلكن
القدره على قراءه العقل فنظره واحده كفيله
بمعرفه ما يدور بداخل الشخص المقابل اضافه
لاستيعابه فكريا
قد يلمس كثيرون هذا الشيء وقد يستغربه
البعض الا ان دراسه قام بها علماء من
جامعه كامبردج اكدت عنق التعاطف الانثوي
المعتمد على نظريه العقل او ما يعرف
بالتعاطف المعرفي
[موسيقى]
وبعيدا عن الدراسه فالواقع الملموس يعكس
ذلك ايضا فالمراه هي الام والزوجه والاخت
والصديقه ولكل من تلك المسميات فيضا من
المشاعر والعواطف والثعلب الاخر
ورغم كل هذه المعطيات الا ان الدراسه لم
تفسر سبب طاعته في النساء المعرفي الذي
يفوق ما يمتلكه الرجال الذين قد يعترضون
ربما على تفوق النسائي عليهم عاطفيا بل
وربما عقليا
[موسيقى]
هذا المجتمع مالتنا العراقي نحنا نشوف
المراه يعني مشاعرها يعني اكثر من الرجال
يعني دائما
تشوفه يعني تصير لمساعده اكثر من الرجال
اكيد الرجل تلقى على الدعسه اكثر دمه حار
من نوع الرجل حساسه الى درجه يعني ما
يتوقعها اي انسان اكثر من مره
همم ملاحظه المشاعر بالنسبه
للرجل ولي المراه لاحظ ان هنالك اختلاف ما
بين المراه والرجل بهذا الموضوع على
اعتبار ان المراه همم طبيعه ملامحها او
تقاسيم الوجه هي تظهر اكثر مصداقيه من
الرجل بالتحديد لغه العيون واذا تلاحظ
سيكولوجيه العينيه تكشف ما بداخل المشاعر
تكون عند الرجال وعند النساء بعض الاحيان
الرجل يشعر انه هو مشاعره اكثر تجاه
المراه والمراه بعض
تكون هي تقرا مشاعر الرجل من خلال احاسيسه
ومشاعرها اتجاهها الشخص الموجود يمها
[موسيقى]
على كل اللي ينضم الينا في ستوديو دكتور
نادر رياضي الاستشاري نفسي دكتور يسعد
صباحك الدراسات تقول ان النساء اكثر ذكاء
عاطفيا من حيث المشاعر من الرجال من
الناحيه العلميه الى اي مدى هذه الرساله
هذه الدراسه عفوا يمكن تكون دقيقه
دقيقه
المراه كيف تقدر تكشف بالعين اول شيء
المراه تتفوق على الرجل في معرفه الالوان
في بعض الاحيان توصل الى ثلاثه اضعاف احنا
كرجال مثلا عندنا ثلاث الوان ثلاث الوان
مهمين اللي هو اللون الاحمر والاخضر
والازرق اللون الاحمر في الاخر مع الرجل
هو يتميز فقط بثلاث درجات مع المراه بيوصل
الى طلب 12 الى 13
مختلفه هذا واحد اثنين في موضوع الاحساس
بالطرف الاخر نعم كهرمون كثيبه كجسد امراه
عمي هي تشعر بالمشاعر اكثر من الشخص او
الرجل هل المراه اكثر قدره على قراءه لغه
الجسد من الرجل
ممكن ممكن نقول دعفان ونصف اكثر لماذا
المراه بتعرف تفاصيل المراه لاختها المراه
المختلفه اللي زيها اكثر احنا كرجال خلينا
نقول لك كيف هي بتتكون هذه الدراسات تتكون
بدءا من النشا احنا كنشاتنا من احنا اطفال
دائما البنت عندها الاكسسوارات تبعتها
اكتر من الرجل احنا الرجل في النهايه
بنطلون قميص كذا كذا انما المراه في عندها
حلق فيها مكياج عند تفاصيل كثير جدا اذا
هي يجب تنتبه الى كل هذه الاشياء هي كيف
احنا بنمرن العقل تبعنا عشان نعرف كيف
يكون احاسيس ان اعلى حتى في الاحساس
التذوق المراه اعلى المراه اعلى اللي هي
الام اللي بدايتها في حياتنا طبعا احنا
كيف اكاديميين هيقول هيك بس عشان نرجع
نشوفها المراه بتستخدم حاله التذوق اكثر
كمان من الرجل الام هي اللي بتبدا معنا
امي وكلتهم بداوا في عمليه الطعام وبعدين
انت لما تزوجتي صارت عندنا احنا الرجل في
رجال حتى اليوم بياكل لحمه ما بيعرف فكانت
لحمه بقر او لحمه خروف انا بعرف ناس
بعرفوا هذه القصه في فرق في كل هذه
الاشياء المراه تتفوق لان هي تتعامل مع
هذه الاشياء عمليا كل يوم فيتم تخزينه في
العقل للعقل الواعي او اللاواعي يتم
استحضار المعلومات هذه زي مثلا امتحان تبع
الصور الامتحان تبع اللي احنا بنتكلم عليه
البادي لانج ويش في المقابلات في هذه
الاشياء تتفوق لان هي بتروح الى الدقه
والتفاصيل مختلفه هارجع اقول لك انا الرجل
في الاخر بقعد في مقهى عشان تطلع على واحد
صاحبي بس هتطلع يمكن مفاتيحه المفتاح
السياره الاشياء هذه المراه بتعمل اسكان
فوق الخيال توخذ الرجل بتوخذ المراه بتاخذ
المكان لا هذا المكان مش حلو هذا كذا
الرجال ما بينتبه هذه النقاط كلها نعم
تتفوق المراه عند الرجل في هذه الاشياء
فلذلك احنا ممكن نوصل لمرحله الاكاديميه
للتحاليل الاول
الدراسه اللي قالت انه بالفعل المراه ممكن
تكون اكثر ذكاء عاطفيا او اكثر ذكاء تحليل
ما الاشياء اللي بتشاهدها لاول دراسه كانت
اجرت دكتور اختبار للغه العيون وكانت
المراه الاكثر تفوقا من الرجال على كل
المعنى مجموعه من الصور لاعين تعبر عن
مشاعر مختلفه سنستعرضها ونحاول قراءتها
معك دكتور استمع لتحليلك نشوف اول صوره
هاي انتهاش شو رايك انا بس قبل ما اعطي
رايي بدي اخبر المشاهدين انه وصلنا لمرحله
انا وسهام صرنا نفهم بعض من لغه العيون
ههه
هلا هي مبينه
هي مبينه مبينه انتاج بس اكيد الصوره تخفي
وراءها شيء ثاني يعني مستحيل تكون هذا
البارز فقط
ممكن يكون فيها سعاده ممكن يكون انا شخص
اكون موجود في المطار
انبهرتوا عندي اندهاش لاني شفت حبيبتي
الانسان اللي انا مستنيه بقى لي فتره ممكن
يكون في اندهاش لانه موقف حدث الاندهاش ما
له علاقه علشان يكون واقعيين الانتهاش
ممكن يكون
الغضب لو في عنا لغه لها علاقه بالغضب
الغضب واضح هيكون الغضب من شيء مش هيسعدني
شوف الصوره اللي بعدها
هلا انا بما انه هي حاطه ايدها على راسها
فبين حدا التامل تفكير بس مش ما مش من نظر
للعيون للتفاصيل كامله للوجه ولغه الجسد
انا بفكر في اشي
سيء شويه مش شيء كثير حلو لما بنطلع
بالعين لفوق نفس المنظر هذا لو اخذناه
وطلعنا لفوق بروح العجز اسمه كرياتف
للابداع دائما انت بتكون عندك فكره حلوه
انت قاعده بتفكري في المقطع او قاعدين هنا
بتلاقي عينك اللي تحت عمره ما بيكون احنا
بنفكر في الشيء جات لي فكره حلوه كثير لا
يمكن اعملها بطريقه كويسه
هاي انا التبني الي بتبناه انه دايما لما
بنطلع بانسان واحنا نفرجه قوت ناطر مباشره
في لغه العيون فكانو هون على نظره ثاقبه
ومباشر مباشره
عشان اعطي له احساس اني انا معك ممكن تكمل
فهي هذه اللغه اللي احنا بنقول حتى في
الاجتماعات حتى في المقابلات حاول تكون
دائما كونتكت تبعك العين زي ما انا الان
بوزعها ما بينكم انتم الاثنين لازم تكون
مباشره فهذه هنا اللغه عين واضحه وصريحه
للشخص الامان
اوكي
ما بعرف اذا في كمان صوره اخيره
[موسيقى]
رايحه الطرف العين على الطرف اليسار
ان انا بروح على حاجه اسمها مامتك يعني
احنا لما بنيجي في بعض الاحيان وادي مش مش
علميا عشان الناس تقول انا بقدر اكشف اللي
قدامي اذا بيكذب او لا دائما لما بسال شخص
له علاقه بالكذب او المنطقه هذه لما
بالاقي عينه بتروح ناحيه الشمال بيروح على
حاجه اسمها الحقيقه او المنطقه اول ما
بيروح العين تبعتي ناحيه اليمين بروح على
الكريات والابداع بدها تكشف جوزها انه كان
المستشفى
كنت قاعده اكس هتلاقيني بتطلع ناحيه
اليمين اه هو كذا والسعر كذا وكذا
يعني كانوا هذه مجموعه هيك سريعه من الصور
طيب وتقييمك لتقييمنا
انتم كمان
هذه نوع من انواع الفراسه ممكن الناس يكون
عندهم الفراشه هذه ممكن اكاديميا طلعوا
العلاقه بين يكتشف لغه العيون ولكن انتم
عندكم حاجتين مستين تختلف عن باقي الاخرين
لانه مجال العمل تبعكم بكشف لكم انتم
بتتقابلوا تقريبا ويكلي لا يقل عن 10
اشخاص بتشوفوهم فسرتوا تكشفوا لغه الجسد
بناءا على الخبرات اللي كسبتوها زائد انه
انتم نساء حنرجع ثاني الاولى عندهم قوه
على الاسكان زي الاسكان الطبيعي انتم
بالضبط زي الاسكان اللي هو له علاقه
بالكمبيوتر الرجل لسه الاسكان الانولوج
القديم اللي يمكن بالهاند بياخذ وقت
الابيض واسود بياخذ معنا وقت لا طبعا كان
انه من البدايه كنت كل الصور اللي انتم
حلتوها كانت حقيقيه
شكرا دكتور
على قراءه المشاعر المراه ولا الرجل وليش
لا المراه طبعا لانه هي بطبيعتها يعني من
عند ربنا هي مشاعرها تكون اكثر من الرجال
[موسيقى]
السبب الرجل بحكم الادوار الممكن يؤديها
في المجتمع
غالبا بيكون هو اللي عنده القدره انه
يتفاعل اكتر بالشهر الرجل بحكم الخبره ان
هو يطلع اكثر يتعرف على اكثر ناس فهو اكثر
همم لقراءه المشاعر
[موسيقى]
المراه اكيد هي اللي دائما تنظر للامور
تعصيله يعني الرجل ما هو فاضي ومشغول في
حاجات يعني اكبر رجل
كل شيء هو رجل كل شيء فاهم في الحياه
يفهمه الاشياء اللي عليه ولا مو عليه بس
الرجل افهم
ما شاء الله متطلع على كل شيء
[موسيقى]